three thousand miles from Cameroon
locked in a museum in Berlin a
centuries-old deity named in Gonzo the
first
that Gonzo was in the museum
I was angry
I was totally angry I was mad the two
million and so people in cameroon's
English-speaking region the ingonzo
deity was pillaged by German colonizers
Sylvie and jobatu is asking Germany to
release her it's a question of Justice
we have the rights to our heritage the
return of this object means that it's
The Reawakening of for the common person
to think about identity Beyond Colonial
boundaries
from 1884 to 1916 Cameroon was a colony
of the German Empire a time of bloody
conquest and frequent Rebellion this
neighborhood in downtown yondi is called
etwa meki in the local language it means
a pond of blood cameroonians believe
that this was a site of a massacre
committed in 1907 by the German colonial
army hundreds of people were killed and
the local Chief was beheaded his head
was then taken away to Germany as a
battle trophy to this day Germany has
not publicly acknowledged the killings
Germany has agreed to return some of the
looted colonial artifacts to Africa in
an effort to confront some of the
brutalities of its Colonial history is
colonial army identified the sacred
objects and would steal them
intentionally to subdue the population
Rebels felt like they had failed their
deity
German authorities have not returned in
goso yet but the statue has been taken
down from the exhibit in Berlin's
Humboldt Forum Museum
says this is the first step in setting
her free and for millions of and so
people to start reinvoking their
cultural identity
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera yaunde Cameroon